please get me on that show
i deserve to be on teen mom
[Music]
i'm carly aquilino and i'm back to
answer the internet if your guy had to
wear a mascot head during sex for the
rest of your life which one would you
choose
a mascot like for a sports team of
course people are like you know like
tony the tiger from [ __ ] tony tiger hot
yes
hi
yeah actually wait no i want to change
my answer the ninja turtles the new
ninja turtles are hot you gotta find
ninja turtles
yeah i do i do the new age version i was
um
they're sexy yes i was um on a date with
a guy and i told him that i think the
new ninja turtles are hot and he was
mortified and he was like i don't
understand what you're saying i was like
they are sexy turtles and i don't know
why we need to talk about this work like
jessica rabbit huh whoa exactly
exactly hotter than normal humans
exactly turtles
but they're like buffs
have you seen them you want like because
you want like a [ __ ] face right yeah
yeah just like a guy yeah just pick me
up
is cereal soup
yes
it's gazpacho
how many chickens would it take to kill
an elephant
probably a thousand but it would have to
be like a dying elephant i feel like
because he would just stomp them we once
had a girl answer like she's like 11. 11
chickens no but they can't even like the
elephant's feet are this big and any
damage they do it would take like
several hours for them to get there if
you can live anyone's life in their body
who would you be
um kate middleton because she's princess
um if you could pick one other part of
your body to cause you an orgasm what
would it be um
i don't know i wouldn't want it to be
something that's like out all the time
yeah like i wouldn't want it to be like
my hand and then i shake someone's hand
yeah
it's like kind of wet
[Laughter]
an armpit too ticklish for that maybe a
leg
maybe a leg make it easy that's where
guys think it is anyway
uh would you rather give up the hangover
breakfast sandwich or the drunk pizza
wow
i think i would
give up the drunk pizza because you need
something when you're hungover to like
absorb all of you need something greasy
and kind of grimy to like absorb all of
that
uh would you rather live in a world
without headphones or a world without
doors i'm gonna say a world without
doors or if someone's in my house it's
fine like
really yeah we're friends
i don't have doors in my apartment well
i have a bathroom door but i have like a
like a straight shot like a like a
railroad apartment so i don't have doors
yeah i mean actually you're right
because if i was like in a relationship
or married or something and i had to go
to the bathroom i would just have to
leave the country
yeah
so okay
uh headphones can i tell you guys
something my parents have never farted
in front of each other and they've been
together for 45 years you [ __ ] go man
yeah people the couple that shits
together and parks together does not
it's too close right and they're always
convincing you like no we're cool like
we're the cool people it's like okay you
guys are weird uh would you rather a
never get oral sex again or b
get only oral sex for the rest of your
life a
never get it again yeah yeah i'm fine
two buttons you can only press one a
instantly get a million dollars or b
have a 50 50 chance that you get 100
million dollars i would do b 50 50
chance at 100 million yeah
yeah
a million
you want to know what though a million
dollars if you start to break it down
it's not a lifetime worth of money so
it's just like i'll i'll roll the dice
you know yeah a million is like
literally half of a studio apartment is
there something that makes you
automatically swipe right on tinder
swipe right is yes or no a deal breaker
for me
i would say would be feet out i'm all
set
and
i'm all set fetish
because like most of the time like a
guy's feed it's like never needed to see
it in the first place and an immediate
yes would be
a cat in the picture
how much money would it take for you to
give up your favorite food for the rest
of your life
50 billion dollars what is it um my
favorite food it's probably
pizza
i would say it's a mix between pizza and
french fries but you just gave up drunk
pizza you idiot i know but you said 50
i guess i would give it up for a
breakfast sandwich in the morning then
can you use a gift card on a first date
no
no you can't
where are you going
where are you going a second date okay a
first date it's like your mommy paid for
this
because you got a gift card for
christmas it's a first date you want to
feel like okay
put in the
bare minimum on a first date period and
then the rest you're going to be an
[ __ ] you could do whatever it's not
like i'm not cool with what you know
it's just a first date
the bar spare me yeah
if every time you finish sex a song
played what would it be billy eilish
that song like
i don't relate to you
would you rather
get pregnant when you're 16 or
get pregnant when you're 30.
i'm sorry 60 30. i think i would rather
get pregnant when i'm 60. because you
already did the things that you want to
do you're established you have your
money
yeah but you're old but you have more
patience when you get older
when you're 16.
that's what i would say i would say 60.
16 my life would have been so different
it would have been like i would have
been a good like teen mom but i wouldn't
have
i have to lose 15 years of my life and
then get pregnant
all right thanks to carliacolino for
answering the internet make sure you
leave a comment below to see more comics
entertainers and celebrities that you
want to see on the show make sure you
subscribe and hit the bell icon to set
notifications
[Music]